[Music]
oh man do this did you know that before
she got her Oscar nomination for
precious empire star Gabby Sidibe was a
phone sex operator
I did not know that well there you go it
was all detailed in our new book but our
senior news editor Jennifer barrows
actually got Gabby to show off her gift
of gab in person not too many people
knew that you were a phone sex operator
I was a phone sex operator from the ages
of 21 to 24 my phone sex voice was
actually just round here so this is like
the normal girl this would be just like
normal girl and then there's barely me
well are like college girl she's a
little bit up here cuz you go in a bit
dumb and then there is dominant girl who
yells at you it's improv I actually was
doing that not knowing that it was
preparing you for like precious thing Oh
like that was my acting school that was
my Julliard
give me a basket please sighs I don't
know yet
I still think about it i watch my figure
the 33 year old oscar nominee and empire
star is brutally candid in her new book
this is just my face try not to stare
from losing her virginity at the age of
20 living in foster care to her weight
loss surgery last year after being
diagnosed with type 2 diabetes are you
happy that's something that you did in
your life yeah yeah I'm happy no regrets
nothing not yet I'm dead pretty good
also like I'm really glad about the way
I did it I didn't tell too many people
the thing about my body is that it's
mine the only opinion that mattered was
mine and that's just the way I kept it
like I don't tell people when I changed
my hair either I just do it Gaby's
living a healthier life and she just
directed her first short film but Fame
is something she's still getting used to
you go through the story of how you're
standing at this premiere next to Mariah
Carey and a dress from the mall and she
was from Payless being like how did I
get here am I supposed to be here
juice do you think right now that you
know you're meant to be where you want
I think so I just want to say that this
is who I am and that I'm working on my
side so her Instagram handle is Gabby
three chamois but she needs to change it
to Gabby not shabby because I love this
girl she is hurt so much people to
understand how much fun gabby is she is
and you know what she's gonna have some
fun this weekend because she's turning
34 happy birthday girlfriend
you
you